We're both graduating from the Electrical Computer Engineering Department...
...at George Mason University this coming May.
We're here, we're just gonna test out our device...
...that we use that uses sound frequencies to extinguish flames.
I see this device being applied to a lot of things.
First off, I think in the kitchen, it can be on top of the stove top,...
...but eventually I'd like to see this applied to, maybe, swarm robotics,...
...where it'd be attached to a drone and that would be applied to forest fires...
...or even building fires where you wouldn't want to sacrifice human life.
Professor Brian Mark really stepped in to help us.
He just gave us a lot of support.
I think as a whole, engineering is really just finding simple solutions to complicated problems.